we have already seen a significant
effort by moscow to make false claims
about europe ukraine and the united
states in an effort to excuse russia's
behavior and potentially create a
pretext for russia to further invade
ukraine
no one should be surprised if russia
spreads disinformation about commitments
that have not been made or if moscow
goes even further and instigates
something as a pretext for further
destabilizing activity as you heard from
the deputy this morning we urge everyone
not to fall for moscow's continuing
disinformation
but the other point is that uh dialogue
and diplomacy are important but we also
need to see progress and progress can
only take place meaningfully uh in the
context of de-escalation uh
de-escalation is not something we have
seen yet uh and in fact
you've we've all seen reports of
exercises and live fire drills that seem
to be
moving in the other direction this was
not an easy discussion
but that is exactly why this meeting was
so important
we had a very serious and direct
exchange
on the situation in and around ukraine
and the implications for european
security
there are
significant differences between nato
allies
and russia on these issues
our differences will not be easy to
bridge
but it is a positive sign
that all nato allies anders sat down
around the same table and engaged on
substantive topics russia raised the
proposals that they published in
december
aimed at addressing their security
concerns
include demands to stop admitting any
new members to nato
and to withdraw forces from eastern
allies
allies on their side
reaffirmed nato's open door policy
and the right for each nation to choose
its own security arrangements
allah has made clear that they will not
renounce their ability
to protect and defend each other
including with
presence of troops in the eastern part
of the alliance
nato is a defensive alliance we have
never forced
or coerced any nation into our alliance
so this idea that for instance
nato enlargement is aggressive
absolutely not true
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have made it clear
and we told the russians directly again
today
that if russia further invades ukraine
there will be significant costs and
consequences well beyond what they faced
in 2014. we remain ready
to continue to engage with russia
the heavy pace of bilateral and
multilateral engagements this week
demonstrates that the united states and
our allies and partners are not dragging
our feet
it is russia that has to make a stark
choice de-escalation and diplomacy or
confrontation and consequences
we expect
and had expected that the russian
delegations at the ssd here at the
nato-russia council and tomorrow at the
osce will have to report back to
president putin
who we all hope
will choose peace and security
they are a powerful country
the fact that they feel threatened by
ukraine
a smaller and still developing democracy
is hard to understand quite frankly
why they need a hundred thousand troops
on the border which they say
are not for invasion but are for
exercising
when live fire exercises are reported
this morning
what is this about
is this about invasion is this about
intimidation
is this about
trying to
be subversive
i don't know
but it is not conducive to getting to
diplomatic solutions so
russia has a choice to make
there was no commitment to de-escalate
nor was there
a statement that there would not be
i think one of the things that russia
has done
which it probably did not expect it has
brought all of europe
nato and na and non-nato allies alike
together
to share the same set of principles the
same ambition the same hopes and the
same commitment to diplomacy
what i think is very important and which
i think russia heard loudly and clearly
from all allies today
is it's very hard
to have
dialogue uh to have diplomacy
uh
that is conducive to success
when in fact
you have a hundred thousand troops live
fire exercises propaganda disinformation
other efforts to subvert that
environment
makes it quite difficult
so if russia wants to reach success
through diplomacy and i certainly hope
they do
because the consequences for them will
be quite severe if they don't
then they should de-escalate
many of things that they put forward are
things that we have heard a number of
times before
we don't agree with their interpretation
of events and we are certainly not going
to subscribe to any rewriting of history
but the fact that we're in the room and
discussing is a small step in the right
direction
in itself
it is only the beginning of a process
which is why the secretary general put
forward his proposals for further
meetings we strongly encourage them to
engage in this process we want them to
de-escalate we want them to change their
posture
towards
ukraine and other neighboring states and
actually get back to a much more
productive diplomatic relationship with
nate